Having understood inodes and the basic characteristics of the
extended file system, let's now consider its merits and compare
it with FAT system. File creating means grabbing an inode
and updating the parent directory. This is not substantially different
from FAT. File growth, just means grabbing a new
data block and updating the inode, no big deal. We
are still efficient in terms of space. There's a little
waste in potentially unused fields in the inodes, and the
indirection tables are space that would not be used if the
file were stored in a FAT system, but this is usually
going to be small compared to the whole size of a file.
As for access time, it is true that the inodes add
an extra layer of indirection as we go through the directory
tree. A directory points to the inode for a file, rather
than to the first state of the block. Because inodes are
cached in memory, however, this performance cost is minimal. Much more important
is that the inodes link the data blocks together in a treelike
structure, with a high branching factor, as many as an indirection table can
hold. This makes for much better random access than one gets from
the linked list chaining of the FAT format, at least for large files.